i appreciate that thank you very much
and for doing what you had to do to get
in here
it is our last show of the season and it
has been 17 days now
since the election uh trump is still
behaving like a psycho beauty
pageant queen who will not let go of the
tiara
and this is also the last time i will
see anybody
publicly before the holidays so merry
and happy because it's been that kind of
year
mary man
god thanksgiving thanksgiving was always
when you pigged out at two in the
afternoon
just passed out on the couch now every
day this year was that
i i i for now on i'm going to be
referring to this period in history
because we need a name for this uh as
the [ __ ]
we had the great recession and then we
had an economic expansion and this is
the [ __ ] that's what we are in now
i mean it's i was in a store the other
day it is depressing uh the the big
hot uh novelty toy item this year for
the holidays is
elfana ventilator this is
i i don't get this country the trump
people they don't want anybody to wear a
mask because they say it's all about
conformity
these are the same people who want
everyone uh to kneel
or not to [ __ ] that joke but
you know the people who they want to
kick you out of the country if you want
you
forget it um you get what i was trying
to get there
okay it's the last show of the season
i'm losing it but
but you know what they can all jump in a
lake because
like no seriously because democrats who
are always preaching wearing the masks
they keep getting caught doing what
we're not allowed to do nancy pelosi did
laurie lightfoot did now gavin newsom
he did you see this he was at some sort
of birthday party indoor i haven't eaten
indoors
publicly since since march without a
mask and at the table there were
lobbyists
from the california medical association
it's like getting shit-faced with
mothers against drunk driving
i good yes let's keep it even
but you know they say there are two new
vaccines uh that and and
that are coming in just in time for the
holidays and this is this is big news
uh they are they say they're almost
impossible to get
and there's about a 90 chance of them
working
maybe i'm thinking of playstation five
oh and the president oh he i tell you
he's in the holiday spirit
yeah he had a screening uh last night of
his favorite holiday movie how the
grinch stole pennsylvania
this guy i mean it just
i mean did you see what team lunatic was
was putting forward this week rudy
giuliani was out there he's having quite
a third act
but he's not looking for his dick in his
pants he's out there
he's out there as trump's lead lawyer
because all the regular lawyers have
quit and he's got a new theory about who
fixed the election
venezuela venezuela apparently he says
dominion that's the the voting machine
company they're actually out of canada
but he says they're owned by another
company which is funded by a venezuelan
associate
of hugo chavez who is dead
at this point msnbc just cut away to a
cuckoo clock
this was like and
wait wait that's not all
spain
spain is involved yes venezuela they
make the machines
that zombie hugo chavez he makes that
but then
the votes got sent he says to barcelona
spain where they were fixed for biden
and then sent
back to the u.s at this point rudy just
kneeled down like james brown
and two handlers came out and put a
straitjacket on him
and then the judge said order in the
court and woody said tanqueray and tonic
please
[Applause]
and then things got weird
i'm going to show you a picture now but
warning the following may be disturbing
to some viewers
viewer discretion is advised
[Applause]
this is what happens this is what
happens when dracula gets out of the
coffin too early in the day
i mean that's his hair dye
you know the trump people are always
saying these colors don't run sometimes
they do
apparently they do sometimes even
jeffrey toobin was like
god that's embarrassing
you